California officials say they've
identified most of the 59 people known
to have died in wildfires that started a
week ago today researchers recovered
searchers recovered eight more victims
of the campfire north of Sacramento
yesterday along with a third victim of
the wolf Li fire in near Los Angeles the
campfire has destroyed nearly 9,000
homes in force at least 52,000 people to
evacuate media BTL is in Paradise
California which was left in ruins by
the fire media good morning well good
morning for the thousands of people that
lived here in Paradise the magnitude of
this disaster is just starting to sink
in they have nowhere to go they have no
jobs and now they have no idea what the
future might hold for them for those
that escaped the camp fire the daily
litany of updated numbers fails to
capture the full impact of the disaster
surrounding them 138 thousand acres 35
percent contained
citizens in shelters 1385 but with
shelters at near capacity and thousands
more displaced many have been forced to
set up camp in this Walmart parking lot
more evacuees more people running out of
money for hotels and families these
before-and-after photos show the extent
of the devastation in Paradise building
after building turned to rubble
government officials say rebuilding
efforts could take years people don't
have that long to wait right now the
Federal Emergency Management Agency is
working with 700 open disasters all
these disasters take multiple years to
get through I didn't expect to move Anna
die says she and her father Gordon were
ready to evacuate when suddenly he ran
back inside the house I honked the horn
in the kitchen collapsed outward and I
knew and I tried again the car and drive
out but the tires had melted Anna
survived all night by waiting in a
shallow pond but she fears her father is
now gone when he ran inside and then he
never came out
investigators are still working on the
cause of this fire but homeowners have
already filed a lawsuit against the
local electric company PG&E now
reportedly that utility is claiming that
right now they face billions of dollars
in possible payments for liability and
right now they do not believe their
insurance company can cover all those
costs so inevitably the consumers might
be on the hook for this Noora yeah that
liability could reach fifteen billion
dollars Maria you're reporting your
team's reporting has been so excellent
thank you so much I know difficult
conditions out there